Prince.
Afternoon, evening.
Hey Travis, how are you?
Doing alright.
How's everything going on?
Fair enough.
Okay, you've been busy, a lot busy with ConnectWise Management and I guess Crystal as well.
Yes, they're still on, we had a team meeting right before this and they're still talking through different things in ConnectWise and how to navigate through it.
Okay.
Very good morning, Travis.
Great, is she is she gonna join?
Partner.
When she's able. I don't know if that'll be anytime soon. I think we could probably get started without her.
Okay, just give me a moment, opening up the deck.
Just give me.
Take your time.
How's things with you, Travis?
Wild.
Just because it is all migration, I mean, at the whole work which is going on at your site, is that that something keeping you busy?
Um...
No, that part isn't.
isn't very burdening, I suppose, at this point. It's all the rest of the business.
Bye.
very busy and we're finding new ways to do a lot of different things and go to new places and adding resources and changing a lot of things that we're doing.
Good, very good problems to have.
Okay, if I understand that.
Sometimes it's a good headache to have, as they say.
Yep, absolutely.
Kip.
Yep.
Did the on the on the renewal quote, did you ever get your answers?
That was going to be my question for this call. I don't think we have, you know, we have really heard on that. And is there something that will go through you only? You know, if I ask Natalie to reach out to you, it should be you, or do I ask her to reach out to somebody else to sign the code?
Have you, have you reached?
Vishal, Vishal, so you were not there in the last conversation we had this. So Natalie is going to connect with Jolene directly and Jolene will collect the feedback from Travis.
Okay.
It's been a while. I just wanted to make sure that that loop was getting closed one way or the other.
Okay, which I hope.
I will get in touch with Natalie and I'll keep you posted on that Travis. As soon as I hear from you, I'll drop a message.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
Yep.
Okay, let me share my screen. Not much to share, but I wanted to keep this check in because we are we stay connected in that way. So good feedback for Agama and Adler. Last week I was unable to join because of some issues. They continue to perform well, no challenges. They have been sharing like.
When the transition to manage happened two days, six hours call, they said like it was kind of very hectic. So I guess this is by June end, we are still in transition or this is completed, Travis. So have we closed the old system yet or not?
No, I was the meeting ran long. I was going to ask him if anybody's been into the old system to check anything. I don't think so. It's getting closed.
I believe the 1st or whatever the following.
Let me check dates. Should be getting shut down the 1st or the 6th.
Okay.
So do you require any help from our end related to manage? I guess that question was specifically for Crystal if she needs any of my help. You do not need help. I know you're already well versed with manage.
Yeah.
I don't think so at this point. We're still bouncing different ways off of our internal ConnectWise resources. And then I'm adding different options available in ConnectWise to accomplish the same task. So it's a combination of them exploring and then finding a new.
thought or idea of what needs to happen and then exploring the options and then implementing one of them.
Blake.
So, as they as they come up, they're getting tackled.
Yeah, so 3rd July offer, Marco, next Friday, I guess.
No.
Well, I have no idea. That's a good question.
Is that enough for you or not?
I'm going to check that right now. I think it is, but I...
I don't think I have it on my calendar.
Yeah.
Yes, the 3rd of July is no business for Marco.
At least you get an extended weekend after such a...
That's good. I got a vacation coming up.
So, that's why it's good to connect. We remind you of your vacations.
Yeah.
Akshay.
Yeah, so for the month of May, performance data is awaited. I know it's going to be busy for you and that's why I did not ping you or call you to share the data because I know the team is busy jumping between the tools and everything and things have been pretty busy. So that's why I did not bug you.
Now when we move on to ConnectWise, July would be the full-fledged month when these guys would be working completely from ConnectWise Management. I would work along with Crystal from August or maybe from September to develop some KPIs to see the numbers and everything so that...
we can actually work off on a good data set for the entire team. I'll work something around that in August to September. Let's see how the data turns out to be in two or three months. So that's one to do I've kept from me from last.
6 to 8 months waiting for this migration to complete.
Yeah, and at that point, we'll probably pick on you to see. For May, I haven't done any of the closing anything for the end of May, beginning of June yet. I owe that to the team and to you guys. For June, I'm going to start measuring it. I have some reports.
built to measure activity and who did what inside of ConnectWise. I got to strip that out. It should be mostly encompassing of what each activity is instead of emails or calls closed finally, the missing metrics and data that I've been wanting.
I got to play around with it a little bit. I'll do that in June, but then we should be able to meet and discuss further in July to see, here's what I'm tracking, what else is available and how do we pull it.
Sure, that helps.
Okay, so the data we do not have any performance data, so we wait for you to share us this data. So that is for the data and upcoming holiday is no planned leaves or holidays in June, but...
Third July is coming up, that's next Friday. So that's it. Agam said like he would require one day off in July, so he would be discussing that with Crystal. And we'll see if that is approved. So that's it. Nothing major apart from this. Anything that you want to discuss?
Kip.
Yes.
How are they feeling about working for Marco and what are they feeling about ConnectWise in general?
Adler is pretty happy because previous to this assignment he was working with Connect Toys Manager. I guess he gave some of his thoughts and those were implemented straight away like this thing. So he's really excited. Agam, since he had been used to that system for any year.
He said, like...
He knows ConnectWise Management very well. It's just that he's thinking like, okay, entire system is changing. So I was working there in that case, so maybe this system will not be fully functional. And that happens when we move on from one system to another like.
Crystal, things like that. So that's there from this aspect from ConnectWise Manish. Overall, they are happy with the work and they are ready to grow in Marco.
Yeah.
All right, good.
I haven't had a chance to talk to him individually yet, just to check to see how things were going, especially for the transition. Adler seemed like he was well adapted and ready to rock'n'roll. He probably has similar thoughts on what we were doing before. This is rudimentary and not quite up to date.
No.
But I wanted to check in to see how everybody was doing with it.
Yeah, Gagan has been used to the system for almost a year, so that's the reason why he is less comfortable, I would say, as compared to Adler.
Kip.
Yeah.
Yeah, but it's more challenging for Adler because he learned one system just for one or two months, and then he switched back to Connect to DESManagement. So the transition for him has been a bit a rollercoaster, I would say.
Yeah, absolutely.
So that's the feedback that I've got. Overall, they are really happy. One thing that stood out, like these bi-weekly meetings, they really like this. Like Agla specifically called it out to me, like, okay, the feedback is being shared with me in front of you by Crystal. I really like that. That's a...
Yeah.
That's a big transparency that I see here.
So...
Good.
That's it. Vishal, you would like to add on anything?
No, I'm good. Thank you so much. Thank you, Travis.
Yeah, absolutely. And I know I owe you guys main metrics as soon as I get to them, which was supposed to be last week and supposed to be this week. I'll certainly share them over.
Yeah, Travis, I would, I can say like you can wait for around one more week and then you can build May and June together. That would be easy for you.
Yeah.
I don't like being a month behind on things.
But, yeah, this...
As soon as you do, as soon as you don't have any escalation from from your end users or client, I think we are good.
Yep, absolutely.
Yeah.
Okay, things seems pretty good. So I'll give you back your time. Thanks for taking care. Bye. Have a have a great day. Thanks, Travis.
But.
Alright, appreciate it.
Yep, thanks. Bye.
Thank you so much, Travis.